I know you had really specific casting
for two of the characters I'm sure the
audience would love to hear which two
you knew who you wanted to play and but
if you can expand a little bit on that
gorge on how it feels to you to see all
of the other characters become
three-dimensional with the actors who
are now embodying them the casting
process
well it's it's you know pretty amazing I
mean way back in 1996 when the first
book came out occasionally people would
say well if it was made in a movie who
would you like to see played a role and
I would say well it can't be made into a
movie so I really don't have to wonder
about that but the question well
nonetheless got me thinking and I did
have I had like a dream casting in 1996
but unfortunately many of those people
from 1986 got older in the interim
instead of saying is exactly as I
remembered them from 96 and by the time
we actually went into production on this
they were too old to play the roles so
but when Dave and Dan sat down there
were two roles we we knew that and that
Sean Bean would would be perfect for Ned
Stark and and he was great and for
Tyrion Peter Dinklage you know that was
the one role where we didn't audition
anybody we didn't read anybody there are
no tapes of other people reading
perience roles that'll ever surface
anywhere because we we made no auditions
we just said we got to get Peter
Dinklage and we went out and made an
offer to Peter Dinklage and we persuaded
them to take the role and that's worked
out well we thought with Sean Bean we
did audition some other people just in
case we couldn't get but thankfully we
were able to get Sean the other roles
that was you know that was a trickier
that was more more ambitious we had a
read a lot of different people you know
searched all over the world I mean you
know our show was shot primarily in
Northern Ireland and Belfast
so we we did a lot of British actors and
Irish actors we did auditions in Belfast
in Dublin and many many auditions in
London but we also did auditions in New
York City in Los Angeles even in
Australia for
few of the few of the parts and we have
truly a global cast that talented actors
from from all over the world on on this
yeah definitely
I wonder if we have any Canadians don't
come to that do we have any Canadian
[Music]
[Laughter]